Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
doctor strange 2 video they just revealed a whole
bunch of deleted scenes from Wandavision that
we're going to feature benedict cumberbatch's
doctor strange teasing the movie so we'll break
it all down there's a whole bunch of easter eggs
confirming a bunch of big theories a bunch of
scenes they basically deleted at the last minute
he was originally a much bigger part of the plot
of all the episodes than we ever believed and some
of the weirder more confusing aspects of the show
make a lot more sense when you hear what he was
doing in each of the episodes if you're brand
new to the channel i'll be doing videos for all
the marvel phase 4 disney plus series be sure to
subscribe to get all those episodes loki is going
to be the next big one so careful for spoilers
for everything that happened on the Wandavision
episodes if you haven't seen those yet but i'll
just start at the beginning here and just number
these as we go along just to stay organized but
you probably saw this week it was revealed that
benedict cumberbatch's doctor strange storyline
during Wandavision started with all the
commercials those weird fake commercials that you
saw in most of the episodes so what was supposed
to happen is that prior to the events of episode
1 right after wanda broke down and created the hex
without really realizing what she was doing just
letting herself be overwhelmed with her grief and
loneliness after kind of being pushed there over
the edge by tyler hayward and sword the really
dark twist on that is that we actually found
out that he was doing that on purpose trying to
get her to use her magic to bring vision back to
life so to speak reactivate him that was why some
of his dialogue sounded so weird like he'd been
developing a working theory that she could somehow
reactivate vision's dead body they've been trying
to reactivate vision's body through that whole
five-year time gap between avengers infinity war
and avengers end game but he successfully pushes
her into that full mental breakdown she creates
the hex and the event is so extreme in magnitude
that it sets off pretty much every single magical
alarm that doctor strange has around the earth
helping him monitor magical cosmic threats threats
from other dimensions because as he told iron man
when they had their big bro off moment his number
one job is protecting the main mcu reality he also
kind of referenced that when he was talking about
loki with thor earlier your brother is on the list
so of course doctor strange sorcerer supreme
would sense when wanda created the hex she was
also doing it in new jersey just one state over
which isn't that far away from the sanctum in
new york city so right after this moment the hex
goes up and wanda drives into westview during the
opening scene of episode one with the fake version
of vision she created hex vision in the 1950s with
everything on black and white and while that's
happening doctor strange is not able to portal
into the hex just to snap his fingers and dispel
the magic make everything go away because of the
way wanda's chaos magic works and scarlet witch
has just gone full blown comic book scarlet witch
too like agatha the hardness said you are the
scarlet witch they explained during episode one of
those flashbacks that she was actually born with
chaos magic in the way they clarify chaos magic
is that it's magic without a cost and it also
gives her the ability to weave spells with magic
without incantations so she doesn't need to learn
a spell out of a book the same way doctor strange
has to learn like he has to read a book to learn
how to do something before he can do it that's
why a little girl scarlet witch here is able to
stop iron man's star tech bomb from exploding
by throwing up a probability spell before she
ever thought about studying magic i did a video
earlier this year about why that happened so in
the comics scarlet witch when she was born was
actually imbued with chaos magic by cathone the
god of chaos so that's why she's born with this
crazy op level of power when she came into contact
with a mind stone it just amplified her power off
the charts so she always had access to chaos magic
it's just that after the infinity stone encounter
it was like the stream inside her turned into
this raging river taking her power off the charts
and that's where you get to that prophecy about
her in the dark hold saying that she's supposed
to be more powerful than the sorcerer's supreme
doctor strange the darkhold was also written by
cathode the god of chaos so that's why doctor
strange wasn't immediately able to portal
into the hex and stop everything on a dime the hex
would not let him in the magic was too powerful
so dr strange's workaround for this during the
series was to try and communicate with wanda
send her subliminal messages to try and get her to
realize what was happening and snap out of it dr
strange was supposed to be the person creating the
fake commercials that we were watching the first
one in episode one was the star tech toaster which
was meant to represent the bomb that killed her
parents that's why you hear the arc reactor sounds
in the same ticking sound that the bomb makes in
the flashback scene from episode 8. it's also
the reason why the same people appear in all the
commercials the second one was for the strucker
watch baron von strucker the experiments he did on
them with the mind stone strucker will make
time for you the third one was the hydra soak
commercial with the tesseract shaped soap and
it was a huge metaphor for wanda avoiding her
problems calgon style calgon take me away from all
my problems into a fake reality that i created for
myself the fourth one was the legos paper towels
which was a reference to her oops quote-unquote
mess that she created during the events of captain
america civil war like the red represents the
blood of the people that she killed inadvertently
through collateral damage when she was trying to
stop crossbones explosion in the yo magic one
was meant to be doctor strange telling wanda
about what agatha harkness was doing to her inside
the hex so that also kind of reveals that doctor
strange knew about agatha harkness the whole time
snacking on her magic so to speak until she would
eventually just withered away like the other
witches from her former coven later you do see
her arms turn gray after agatha starts to siphon
off some of her magic in that last one the whole
nexus commercial was doctor strange being way
more overt about it trying to explain to her how
she was a nexus being in the multiverse basically
like the same everywhere like one wanda across the
entire multiverse in the comics nexus beings with
these big focal points for energy which also sort
of goes hand in hand with the idea that she's this
mythical being the scarlet witch but during the
commercial there's the dialogue saying you should
not take nexus unless your doctor has cleared you
to move on with your life and the woman picks up
the nexus pills from the doctor that was supposed
to be doctor strange more overtly referencing
himself like doctor strange is the doctor and
he's telling wanda that he's going to help treat
her like a regular doctor and help her learn about
her chaos magic powers and sort out this big
prophecy in the dark hold about her bringing
about the end of the world you have to remember
the reason why he's called doctor strange isn't
because he's sorcerer supreme he's called doctor
strange because he is a medical doctor then what
would have happened after that is that during the
finale he would have finally appeared on screen
taught her what it all meant how chaos magic works
in how to use those runes that she uses to trap
agatha harkness he would have also helped her sort
out what was going on with billy and tommy as well
like they have that big post credit scene tag that
was always going to be part of the series teasing
doctor strange 2 more overtly but according
to kevin feige what had happened was is they
had signed benedict cumberbatch to this special
contract to do the Wandavision episodes all of his
scenes and then the virus happened so for a number
of different reasons they had to rework a lot of
the plot and they just rewrote things and rewrote
things again then at the last minute when it came
time to make a decision about benedict cumberbatch
they opted to just leave him on the cutting room
floor so to speak and completely rewrote the
finale also because they got rid of his scenes
and he was such a big part of the plot they had to
rework and add some extra scenes in reshoots later
like this scene where they're fighting each
other and she throws the runes up around the heck
surprising agatha harkness during the re-shoots
they had to add that dialogue where she says no
one taught me how to do this because they wanted
it to feel like wanda figured this out herself
instead of benedict cumberbatch's doctor strange
teaching her how to do it which was originally
what was going to happen the post-credits scene
that they have with her studying from the dark
hole trying to learn more about chaos magic was
always going to be part of the series and it was
always going to be a direct teaser for doctor
strange 2 billy and tommy were always going
to be crying out to her from the multiverse so
to speak at least that's what they're implying
like they're crying out to her from some other
dimension and she's going to go and try and find
them during doctor strange 2 and when it came to
teasing the villain of doctor strange 2 because
everyone has theories about who that's going to
wind up being if it's going to be cathode the god
of chaos because it kind of seems what they're
implying during the series or if it's going to
wind up being nightmare completely different
character or if they're even going to reference
mephisto i do love the theory that billy and
tommy crying out to her from the multiverse or
from some other dimension is really a trick of
the villain of doctor strange 2 trying to bait
her to do something to use her magic to bring
about this prophecy that's inside the dark hold
so essentially kevin feige says they got rid of
benedict cumberbatch's scenes because they didn't
want him to undermine wanda's character arc during
the series they were worried that if he showed up
in the finale that's all anybody would be talking
about and everyone would just completely forget
about wanda's character arc and kevin beige
said that he didn't want Wandavision as a series
just to feel like it was a glorified teaser for
doctor strange too so it sounds like originally
they had planned for way more doctor strange
2 crossover scenes and easter eggs throughout
all the different episodes it confirms a lot of
theories because there were various points during
the series where it felt like they were trying
to reference doctor strange too or benedict
cumberbatch's doctor strange in some way after
the Wandavision finale and after the falcon and
winter soldier finale a lot of the people behind
the series the different producers talked about
trying to create the show in the edit room the
same way that they create the marvel movies like
they'll shoot a whole bunch of stuff they'll try
a bunch of different things then they'll try to
sew it all together in the edit bay so that it all
makes sense and sometimes that works better than
others like it doesn't work quite as much on a tv
show where you really have to plot everything out
pretty carefully in advance so if you felt like
there were some continuity gaps or some things on
Wandavision didn't make sense it's because they
rewrote a lot of things at the last minute and
tried some things that were completely different
from their original plan that they had plotted out
but everyone let me know in the comments what do
you think about all these doctor strange deleted
scenes that were going to be setting up doctor
strange 2 their big crossover moments during
the Wandavision episodes do you think they made
the right call and just deleting all that stuff
and just leaving all their big crossover stuff
for the actual doctor strange 2 movie we're
probably going to get that first doctor strange 2
trailer in a couple months so we want to wait too
long to see what's going on with that cannot
wait to see what sam raimi did with that movie
congratulations liam gohagen you're the giveaway
winner from my last big marvel video please email
me on the about page of my channel so i can get
your contact details everyone click here for that
brand new marvel phase 4 trailer in the eternals
trailer and click here for my brand new loki
episode 1 trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!